you guys are just getting started you're
not going to start right here you're
going to start down there probably in
another city another town I grew up in
Lake Charles Louisiana no money raised
by a single mother I was in debt at 25
years old first thing that I had to do
in my life was not learn a new skill
first thing I had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development it is vital it was
vital for me that I improved myself and
I could start depending upon me I had to
show up every day with some rituals some
disciplines and start getting myself to
trust me not trust others but trust
myself to do the right thing every day
one of the things that I started doing
was beating the Sun up every morning I'm
going to beat that son up every morning
so that I had the discipline and the
control of over my life so I knew hey
before that thing pops I'm gonna pop I'm
gonna get out of bed depend on myself
get up at the same time every day and
for me that time regardless of where I
was was beat that son up no matter where
I am I'm gonna beat that thing up so it
gives me a sense of control over my own
life second thing I had to start
cleaning up my life and my friends and
my environment when I was younger
between 15 and 25 I was doing crazy
stuff in my life wasting my weekends I
had the same weekends or for the week I
was drinking fooling around with a bunch
of bad things bad people at 25 years old
I cleaned it all up quit going to those
places quit hanging out with people that
did not have ethics and discipline in
their life I wanted to build something
in my life I wanted to become someone
and to do that to become someone in the
eyes of the world just beating that sun
up every morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that I did what I said I
was going to do that I woke up when I
said I would wake up and I started
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that I can go out
into the world and maybe maybe today
when I go into this meeting that I'm
dressed for they'll believe in me as
much as I believe in me and that'll show
up in a contract a deal maybe even some
money need motivation watch the top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business this I quit
I'm a business partner I struggled to
keep going I was making 300 bucks a
month and felt like a complete failure
and the thing that saved me that pulled
me up was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today this one from one of
the best Grant Cardone and my take on
his top 10 rules of success and enjoy
rule number two never give up never give
up on your financial goals until you
achieve your financial goals there's
people in this room folks that are going
to be worth billions of dollars
there's a billionaire in this room right
now I'll guarantee you could be two or
three up
billionaires in the making right here
okay questioning who's it going to be
now if somebody in this room how many
believe this is somebody in this room
made a decision I'm going to put
together a billion dollars how many
believe that's possible
everybody in the room believes it's
possible you might not think it's
possible for you but you know it's
possible which means what the money's
available
would you would you do good things with
that billion dollars
okay you know that about yourself you
don't know about the guy sitting next to
you
you know that about yourself
so you know somebody could do it and you
know if you did it you do good things
with it right
so go do it man because the money's out
there there's plenty of it and I grew up
with a little uh five uh four foot 11 uh
Italian lady that knew nothing about
money she just knew hold on clip coupons
save your money how many were brought up
like that Penny saved is
Penny earned say for a
see you were brought up the same way I
was eat all your
eat all your food if you don't eat it
all save it put it in the refrigerator
right some of you got you got food in
your refrigerator right now three and
four five days old
you have you have no intention eating it
some of you got you got like an eighth
of a bagel left from five days ago
right now you're like okay it's in there
right now you got you got you got ice
cream in your in your freezer that's
like six months old
it's expired twice
it's got that much frost on it but you
got one bite left
I know it's still good you tell your
kids this too you pass on the same
[__] to your kids eat all your food
eat all your food eat all your food and
then you wonder why we got obesity
problems in America
we live in a country that's rich and the
people have scarcity in their minds we
number three focus on results what is a
mindset or belief that you have
that you feel most of the time people
disagree with you on
well I think a lot
I'm a positive person and I'm not okay
this has nothing to do with positivity
or motivation
uh I I'm not I'm not like
you know Mr beat my chest I'm excited
and I'm gonna I'm gonna see myself
through this because I'm gonna will
myself through it no I'm not gonna do
that like I'm gonna do something
what I'm gonna do is do something I'm
going to make a call I'm going to send
out an email I'm going to follow that up
I'm going to build a team that can do
the same thing like I am going to win on
action
and it doesn't mean it's it doesn't mean
I'm gonna outwork you
I'm going to out result you
so and I'm not trying to out result you
by the way I'm just like I need to I
need to get results in the marketplace
so I remember uh Gary vaynerchuk was in
my studio once and he was telling me
he's like I'll outwork you I'm like bro
you I mean we just met it you don't know
me I don't know you I don't know what
your work ethic is I don't know what you
do and there's no way you can know
whether you outwork me or not and by the
way it doesn't even matter
what matters is do we get results and so
what we've been successful with this
whole 10x thing is about hey I am going
to set a Target
10 times higher than what I need for
myself and I'm going to do whatever I
have to do between now and the
attainment of that Target to get that
that is not a mindset it is a decision
but it's not some positivity thing or
enthusiasm like I think people mistake
that I think that's what that's to
answer your question rule number four
change your thinking I'm talking to an
audience that wants to get rich just
trying to really like make something
make something big yeah like become like
Robert Smith Rich you know he's the
wealthiest black man in America or Don
peoples my friend who's worth a couple
billion dollars in playing in the real
estate game or you know like I I want to
get to the top of the food chain where I
get to start making rules he who has the
goal makes the rule and so I don't want
a little money I don't want a retirement
account I don't want my house paid for I
don't care about any of that stuff I
want to get rich I want to create
tremendous amounts of wealth for for the
people that that my community for the
people it started off for my handful
like me my wife my kids and then once
I'm like okay I can help more than that
I can help I can I don't mean my
neighborhood
people in my neighborhood can be helped
right okay they can be helped they need
help and by the way where I live right
down the street they just don't know
they need help they're rich but they're
not wealthy they're not helping anybody
else dude they're just helping
themselves it's freaking terrible it's a
life of poverty to have your house paid
for it's a mental poverty like oh I got
my house paid for I got my two cars my
kids are going to private schools and
I'm miserable because there's no purpose
uh like I'm helping millions of people
around the world also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five keep yourself
busy what are you going to do on a daily
basis you got to keep yourself busy you
got to figure out some kind of way to
keep yourself busy they're going to
share with you my team's going to share
with you a little schedule I use I'll be
talking about goal setting how to set
goals how to achieve goals how to keep
your calendar full because if your
calendar is not full and you said okay
I'ma quit doing dumb stuff and I'm gonna
I'm gonna quit hanging around these
idiots
um well the truth is you got nothing to
do and you're going to sit around and
boredom is going to get you and you're
going to go back and you're going to
start doing the same you were doing with
the same people you were doing it with
it wasn't until I filled up my calendar
with activities
and then got good at those activities
that my life actually changed and the
last thing was I had I needed to start
adding some people that could change my
life so the last three things is you got
to get better at something keep your
activities full when you're winning when
you're doing things you're good at you
will want to do it a lot you will not
burn out on things you're doing well and
the other thing is you've got to get
around the right people rule number six
invest in apartments
why do I insist that apartments are the
greatest investment of the group why
should you focus here for your initial
foray into real estate investing in
short it's because Apartments passed a
number of tests that are vital to you
not having to worry about whether or not
you're going to make money in a deal
okay you're here to win you're here to
make money I'm all in on apartments for
key reasons first apartments or real
assets when you own apartments and you
own real tangible assets you benefit
from a number of things one you benefit
from appreciation going forward forward
if you picked a good location cash flow
right now while you sit and wait and
it's more expensive in the future going
forward to build these apartments than
it was to buy them number two apartments
produce positive cash flow at least they
should if you bought it right if you got
the right debt on it and if you pick the
right property Apartments produce
positive cash flow which is the Holy
Grail of finance a concept that very few
people ever get right almost as
importantly as inflation same thing with
cash flow you're underestimating the
value of positive cash flow when you
pick a property it is cash flow that
gives it value going forward because one
you get to keep it long term and two it
gives you security when you go to sleep
at night now that brings me to number
three this is called the multiplier
effect when rents rise if they do in
your Market apartment values increase if
you're ready to take the next step and
start investing in real estate like a
total Pro you have to start with the big
why why a particular class of asset rule
number seven always stay broke stay
broke stay broke y'all got to stay broke
man cash is garbage you don't need money
you don't need cash cash is trash your
mommy and daddy didn't know this cash is
garbage it is trash take it out use it
it is worthless until it is put to work
okay listen to me money is worthless
until it is put to work
money is useless until it is used
it's a piece of paper
okay it's got God on it look how they
treat this let's put God on there man
okay we'll put a we'll put Ben Franklin
it wasn't God's idea to have his his
name on a piece of paper everybody agree
with that that's a that's a pitch
come on man put Ben Franklin on this
right he's a president
okay like he ain't he ain't my president
he did
and then we act like a sacred I got to
keep it and protect it now it's mine
this is what this is what uh Brandon was
doing this morning we're talking about
currency if you look at the word it
comes from current current flows it has
to be in circulation
right it's it's it's plentiful it's a
piece of paper it's only valuable when I
take it out of my pocket get it out of
the system and put it to work
if I give it to the bank if I call up
Wells Fargo today and say Here's a
hundred dollars what are they gonna do
with it
they're going to convert it it instantly
converted into digits and then they will
send it out nine times
almost 10x rule number eight help others
look this these five days it's 90
minutes a day you guys carve about 90
minutes for me every day for five days
completely free cost you nothing
and I promise you I will put you on
track to become a millionaire yeah man
you know so it's not difficult but you
got you I can't do the willingness thing
you guys got to sign up for it I can't
do and I know some of some of your
audience are like ah what's the strings
attached what's it uh the strings that I
want to help that's the string okay if
you've ever asked for help beg for help
prayed for Help Wanted help wanted
somebody to take time to help you this
is a gift yeah and it's my gift to you
and those that receive the gift it gives
me a gift back to me to fulfill my
purpose so I truly want to help people
uh this is not about inspiration or
motivation it's not about you getting
all excited and beating your chat is
real tactical dude it's a strategy it's
a specific strategy yeah and I'd like
I've never needed motivation I don't
need anybody to motivate me I don't need
to jump up and down to get excited I
don't I don't need to do a cold plunge
to want to conquer the world or walk on
fire dude I need a strategy just show me
the math yeah and and show me that and
then I'll take it from there and I'm
gonna figure it out just like you did
rule number nine be with the right
people I've created leverage on my
Leverage
on your leverage on your leverage on
your leverage on your leverage you'd
leverage your leverage like 15
000 times it's unbelievable
yeah I like like in 12 years I didn't
know I could do this right it was
because people started believing and be
Man one and and then and then when I
started seeing other people do this when
it became real to me
you know that
you know when I saw oh wow what was I
thinking
what was I thinking I'll tell you one of
the biggest culprits
one of the biggest thieves in our
society and one of the biggest mistakes
I made in my career was like simply just
not being around the right people
I was around people that loved me when I
should have been around people that had
done something
you know oh man I love her so much I
love this but they hadn't done anything
like like guys you know you can love you
you know
you need to get around some people that
have done something so you can take care
of the ones you love
because if you're not around people that
have done something you can't really you
can only do to the degree that you're
around winners
I'm sorry your golf game's not going to
get better playing around guys that
don't know how to play golf and Rule
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is dream big hey you
guys keep asking me what enough money is
how many times I got to tell you first
of all if you're asking a question you
don't have enough money number two
enough money by definition at least my
definition would be you can take care of
everyone you love everyone's all the
people your sister that you forgot about
your aunt that took care of you when you
were growing up maybe a school teacher
that helped you out a bunch is
struggling now but you can help your two
kids your wife or husband
and your parents and beyond that you
know what I'm saying you can reach deep
start helping all the people you love
that would be enough money and still
take care of yourself by the way I know
some of you out there taking care of
everybody else but you don't take care
of yourself so you'd have to be able to
take care of everybody you love all the
people you forgot that you love of and
the people that can't take care of
themselves the guy on the street corner
that you're like dude I feel sorry for
this guy I want to help him out you can
take care of all those people and
yourself and I'm not done
okay
when you expire and you're done your
history you can't work anymore can't
produce anymore you're you're expired
you would steal you had enough money to
still take care of the people you love
the the things you love the Charities
you love the causes that you believe in
yeah that's what would be enough money
and still not be out by the way
you would have abundance in every way
you would have Wealth Beyond anything
that's destructible
it would last forever and you could
literally change the world
with the money that you produce because
you were committed
you were charitable
cared enough to go big enough
you guys man y'all just don't care about
enough people that's why you think so
small
[Music]
it's not about the cars
and the shades and the clothes and the
watches yeah all those things are cool
and everything but the real game is can
you create enough wealth
continue
and you can by the way it's possible for
anyone to do if you dream big enough
it's not possible if you don't make this
big
but if you did think this big it could
think this big if you got around other
people that felt this big
they'd encourage you to think big and
really live into your full potential
[Music]
to create create you could absolutely
100 starting from zero still create
enough wealth to take care of you all
the people you love all the people you
forgot that you love and even when
you're done
you could keep taking care of people
I was 28 years old three years sober no
drugs in my body for three years I'm
selling cars
and I'm getting good at it too like you
come in and say look I got bad credit
and I'm not buying today I'm like oh
that's two cars
I'm a penalize I'm a penalize you for
saying that more okay okay
yeah man you got bad credit that's
perfect
[Music]
got some credit
see I ain't positive I'm there to get
something
so so Captain Ryan says to me he's like
you're the most positive person I know I
said dude I'm not positive at all
I'm 10x
I get results
okay I want to get the deal done I want
to make my kids proud of me
my kids aren't going to remember whether
that was positive or not they're going
to remember whether daddy delivered the
goodies or not
you understand when you go to Whole
Foods and they say hey that'd be 427 for
three bags
[Music]
and you're like I got a good attitude
they'd be like you need to get some 10x
you need to get some 10xes and money to
go with your freaking attitude
I was 30 years old and I was starting to
speak around the country
and a business partner that I've been
working with for three or four years he
said look I said dude I'm a crossover
I'm working on this one vertical how
many how many of you depended upon a
vertical
maybe your chiropractor or dentist or
insurance or you're in real estate or
you're you work your Sprint
right and you're you got this vertical
and you're like dude I love my vertical
my vertical makes me feel good my
vertical pays the bills oh
[Music]
dependent upon the vertical I'm a little
worried that that that that that you
know what I'm saying
I gotta keep doing this thing
and I kept telling this guy I said one
day I'm gonna cross over to a mass
audience he says you'll never do it
nobody ever does it McGraw-Hill
McGraw-Hill you know the book publisher
McGraw-Hill they wouldn't publish
a book called seller be sold
because they said it was a sales book
I said yeah and I'ma sell some books too
National Geographic canceled the
turnaround King how many of you saw that
show
canceled it CNBC copied it picked it up
threw it up on the thing
look this is what's gonna happen to you
folks how many of you have a dream
[Music]
hey hey you gotta go get it
okay dreams don't happen on couches and
they don't happen in bed if you're gonna
realize that dream you got to go out
into the marketplace you gotta meet a
new you
you gotta go through obstacles and
barriers to where it's like that only it
doesn't even bother me anymore
right Elena 26 phone calls because I
wanted to close the deal she didn't want
to go out with me I'm too short yeah
okay I'm too short how short am I at 51
000 feet
[Music]
how short am I now huh
how shirt am I now goddamn
uh how short am I now we're scoring 666
miles an hour right now at 51 000 feet
huh huh I'll show them right now
the plane that I bought it was an
expansion decision
the accountant said it doesn't make any
sense man you don't fly enough it's
gonna cost you too much
you don't go on those trips I'm like
dude am I gonna expand or contract it's
been 30 years 30 years it's probably
going to be 30 years for you too
doubt uncertainty insecurities
rejection disappointment judgment it's
going to be 30 years of it if anybody
thinks
you're going to be successful without
paying that price
you're wrong are you willing to pay the
price you see this financial statement
right now right here everybody has one
some of you are seeing one for the first
time in your life financial statements
everywhere in the world whether I go to
Cincinnati or Singapore they're
identical I go to Dubai or I go to
Taipei or I go to Sydney Australia
financial statement the languages are
different the culture is different the
foods are different everybody agree the
colors of the skin might be different
the financial statement is the same
everywhere
and they all start like this okay
there's there's there's this much of it
this the revenue of the company
typically there's this much revenue and
there's that many expenses
okay which one's more powerful
this is more powerful than that
okay I need to spend 95 of my time on
the top part of this you see where it
says Revenue gross sales Less sales
returns and allowances net sales that
little that little piece right there you
can take to Infinity
that you could take the zero and that's
it you can never get it lower than zero
and like if that don't Boggle your mind
if that little simple concept I can take
expenses to zero I can take gross sales
to to infinite how big can I imagine
okay how do I pay for the jet sales
how do I pay for the 19 country trips
sales
okay who's going to give me a sale
people the Top Line those top line is
people 95 of your time should be spent
on income and people people have
everything you want
the people that you know do not have
what you want the people that you don't
yet know have everything you've dreamed
of
so how old are you sir
57 years old the people that love him
and care for him that have taken care of
him that support him have had plenty of
damn time to change his life
he needs to now say okay I've been
looking at the wrong damn place
okay he now needs to meet the people
that can change his life because it's
not his mom his dad his uncle his
grandpa his kids the people that love
you are not going to change the quality
of your life they've had plenty of time
to do that I was talking to some Wall
Street guys and I'm like do that
I hate these Wall Street people
and I said they're just I'm just not
accepted there I'm not like them and the
guy looked at them he says bro it's
because you're talking to the wrong
people he didn't say bro by the way but
he says it's because Grant he's like
Grant you're not talking to the top of
the food chain
the top of the food chain
is exactly like you um that's
interesting they would never judge you
they would never criticize you they
would only admire you they would want to
pick up the bill with you they would
think they were with a brother
he says it's everybody they hired below
him that is threatened by you
they said the reason you don't feel
comfortable talking to these people is
because you're talking to one level
below who you should be talking to and
that level seems like a level above
because it could be a level above where
you're at because but it's a different
game it's a different playing field the
guy looked at me says look bro you're a
Savage you're a beast you have to talk
to Savages and beasts yeah you're not
you're not built to be a corporate guy
that's not you like the reason you the
reason you're uncomfortable Grant he's
like the guy told me and he's this guy's
way up there he says the reason I
believe you've had problems is because
you've simply been dealing with the
wrong people
and in thinking that you needed those
people
you know and and the reality is you are
those people you're studying why do I
love real estate why does Real Estate
build Financial Freedom number one
protects your capital okay if if I buy
this deal is the money is the money is
the cash the money that I put down to
buy this deal is the money gonna be
worth more or less in the future
another cash
cash is worth less in the future what
about this building
only by the way not all buildings are
worth more in the future
if the building's in a good location and
it stays occupied and rents can rise it
will be more worth more money in the
future okay I want you to be sure you
guys understand this not all real estate
goes up in value
you think it's good to be liquid
I would encourage everybody in the room
to stay illiquid
Wall Street wants you to be liquid the
banks want you to be liquid okay the
courts want you to be liquid your lawyer
wants you to be liquid
because as long as your liquid
they can grab it from you
you understand
like if you're liquid you're never going
to file for bankruptcy
you'll never ever tap into a bankruptcy
option
if you don't have a lot of debt you
can't use the bankruptcy courts
which are put there to protect you from
losing everything
now I've never filed bankruptcy because
my real estate got me through all the
hard times 2 000 2010 2020 covid my
apartment's got me through when our
other business hurt despite what you
guys saw in the news by the way when
rental apartment rentals we're going to
go to 84 70 the world was going to go to
hell we collected more rent during covid
than we collected the previous year
did you even have the courage to borrow
money because if you don't have the
courage to borrow money you will never
have net worth and you will never have a
good credit score everybody agree
and you don't need to worry about your
credit score how many how many of you
you've been told you need to raise your
credit score in order to be free on this
planet no you need net worth
to be free on this plan excuse
completely made up
nobody needs a pair of fendies and my
wife does not need six inch heels
everybody agree
okay you don't need all that stuff
but we made it up so you got a product
you got a service and now we can sell it
to people but you do need a place to
live and you need water and you need
food everybody agree I gotta have
something over my head to shelter me
from the
the exterior I need some food and I need
some water those things will not change
no matter what happens with the internet
Amazon cannot replace housing
it can replace where you get your books
so when I'm watching Blackstone take
okay why are they taking currency
converting it to buildings
okay they take and write a check they
wrote a check for the entire thing no
debt ten thousand houses they then
waited filled it up with renters I'm
watching this in 2008 filled it up with
renters and then what they did was they
refined the entire process
sold it as bonds
to your grandmother
they pay your grandmother like two and a
half to three and a half percent
okay your grandmother's so happy that
every quarter she gets a little freaking
bang
they probably worked with AIG to do this
or State Farm or Allstate or Prudential
or MetLife or New York Life insurance
companies backed most of my real estate
transactions
okay because real estate real estate is
is that thing that an insurance company
can use to depend on to pay for your
life benefit you should write this down
every day this year is either going to
be better for me or it's going to be
worse for me my marriage is either going
to get better this year or it's going to
get worse my money's going to get better
or it's going to get worse my health is
going to get better my health is going
to get worse what I do today will
determine whether it's going to be
better or whether it's going to be worse
it will not be up to trump it will not
be up to the Democrats it will not be up
to something that happens in Iran it
won't be up to the stock market it's up
to you first get rid of the little think
and the old ideas and the middle class
mentality I'm gonna go to work I'm gonna
save some money I'm gonna put it in the
bank I'm gonna give it to the Man what's
the bank dude the bank doesn't need to
keep your money they hate money cash is
it's trash cash is garbage it's pieces
the garbage paper it is only useful when
it is used they didn't teach you this in
school this should have been taught
basic fifth grade sixth grade not in not
when in high school or college cash this
is a piece of paper okay it is a piece
of paper it's worthless this is a piece
of paper this actually has more value
this piece of paper right here has more
value than this piece of paper right
here why because one person has this
piece of paper
2 000 people have this data
you understand this piece of paper right
here is useless though until it is used
foreign
how many of you were taught to say stuff
how many of you got sticky notes and you
save them you write you write like 17
different things on one sticky note
I know I don't want to use the whole pad
[Music]
I'm gonna make this I'm gonna make this
sticky pad last the rest of my life
okay you got to get rid of the little
thing folks this little thing is killing
you let's find out if you got the little
thing
how many believe success is a mind game
dude this starts right here you got to
fix this you got to get rid of let's
find out if you've been affected
okay I want you to look at your
refrigerator at home
what's in it
water
nothing's in it it's empty
it's very frugal of you
let's buy a refrigerator keep it empty
okay
huh
leftovers what kind of leftovers
what do you got in there
[Music]
a week old salad he opens the
refrigerator maybe tomorrow
I don't want to throw it away
why
because his mother taught him that eat
all your food eat all your food eat all
your food how many of you brought up
like this three times a day eat it all
when I met a late night I called my mom
I said
[Music]
she's like have y'all been out yet I
said no she hates my guts
she wants nothing to do with me okay
kind of like I felt about Pete the first
time I met Pete I told Jared I said I
want nothing to do with him
it's a true story he's like can I get
five minutes sure
[Music]
I'll give you five minutes might be 15
seconds
boom he made an impression with me first
impression is
what's first impression
last Impressions more important than our
first impression most the People You
Meet they're gonna have a bad first
impression of you
okay most of the people I meet do not
like me my wife had she did not not like
me she didn't even see me
[Music]
she didn't like I was invisible to her
she couldn't remember what had black
hair brown hair short tall she didn't
remember nothing like she's like huh who
are you I met you last night huh
yeah you know the god the guy the guy in
the RV uh-huh so so look no matter what
you do there's gonna be people that
don't know you
right you're going to be humble Elena
did not know me did not want to know me
did not want to get to know me my mom
said Grant if she don't like you it
takes two grand it takes two how many of
your parents told you that before it
takes two you gotta have two people in a
marriage and I told my mom thank you
thank you Mom thank you and I hung up
and I'm like she wrong again
it don't take two folks it takes one
person to make a relationship work it
takes one person to make a sale you know
me things I've sold in my life where
nobody wanted to buy it
okay almost probably probably eighty
percent of everything I've ever sold
with some to someone that didn't want to
buy it
the other 20 wanted to buy something
from me
last thing I'm gonna say it was his idea
and our idea to get you here
you you you got sold this
you didn't buy this you understand that
okay don't be saying oh yeah I bought it
no you didn't you got sold this
okay we sold you on coming here you this
wasn't your idea you didn't call them
say hey I'd like to come down to the 10x
headquarters I'd like to give you guys
money it's been a couple days that are
learning
[Music]
in fact uh would you guys do a challenge
put a challenge together and sign me up
for a lot of others right as well
[Music]
our idea to get you here
okay and that's the same thing that's
going to happen for your audience it's
not going to meet them wanting to do
something with you you got to decide it
takes one person to make a sale
it never takes a buyer almost never
takes the buyer takes me to walk up and
say this is what we're doing hey to all
of you out there that are having a hard
time right now
if you bet you're getting beat up
maybe you're broke you don't have any
money girlfriend or boyfriend left you
had a loss in your family
[Music]
lost your job
I got a little message for you okay
here's the deal
number one it can get worse
okay it can get a lot worse than it is I
know I've not always lived up here when
views good
I'm telling you
keep feeling sorry for yourself it's
going to get worse and worse and worse
now
with the prevalence of experts
on the internet including Instagram
YouTube Facebook Snapchat Twitter
and the
plethora of people that literally
can make quotes and memes knock off
Abe Lincoln's quotes and take credit for
him
there's no shortage of people out there
saying it's going to be easy for you to
be successful
look it's not going to be easy okay the
advice you're getting out there is so
wide open there's so many people telling
so many people garbage
like it's going to be easy you're going
to be able to travel all over the world
all you have to do is become an instant
celebrity or a star on
any channel or
all you have to do is start posting
pictures of you and cars or you on trips
or you working out or look it's just
it's endless and it's driving me nuts
that some of you out there that are
getting your brains
like handed to you
and you're sitting there you're like
whoa it's me what what is wrong why
can't I make it all these people are
making number one you don't even know if
they're making it
you don't really know if they're making
it you don't know what their life's like
or if they're happy or or if they're
really successful if the money's real if
the cars are really if the trips are
real you don't know any of that so so
number one don't
feel sorry for yourself nothing's going
to change because you feel sorry for
yourself I lost five my first five jobs
I was broke at 25. the more educated I
got the more broke I seem to be my mom
and my twin brother said look leave us
alone get your freaking stuff together
and then uh maybe you know earn your way
back into our Graces I was the black
sheep of my family I didn't even like
myself and me blaming others need
feeling sorry for myself didn't change
things and most importantly and maybe a
benefit to me was there was nobody on
the internet at that time saying
uh I became an internet store and that's
how I made my millions of dollars
I just wasn't available only thing
available back then was you got to work
okay you got to work you got to go out
into the marketplace you got to pick up
a phone you got to start where you are
you have to take that sucky crummy job
that you have and do whatever it takes
to start putting money together you
don't need to go back to college you
don't need to go get another degree
some of you got so many degrees you
could be a freaking uh thermometer
like you got to change the game okay you
got to get tools and skills simple tools
and skills so you can start monetizing
whatever your skill is
so number one you got to knock off the
excuse making it can get a lot worse I
promise you it can get terrible I
thought it was bad at 23 it got worse
okay it got worse so I want to help you
but you got to drop the quick get rich
quick thing it's gonna be easy I'm gonna
become a star I'm just going to start
knocking off other people's quotes I'm
going to put up pictures of uh uh of
cars and trips and and think that that
makes me successful it's not okay you
can't steal somebody's profile and think
that's going to make you successful
got to work
you have to monetize okay if your daddy
didn't leave you with a business you
have to go out and do something today
today that adds value to the marketplace
and get you money
okay money
nobody's telling you go get money
sell a product okay now you could sell a
product out of your closet but you're
not gonna be able to duplicate that
again tomorrow so I strongly suggest
that you get products that you can sell
a second time a third time a fourth time
a fifth time you got people out there
just dropping f-bombs telling you don't
do anything you don't want to do don't
do the stuff you're no good at
well you're not good at anything right
now so you've got to do something right
now everybody has to start somewhere
starts with you taking responsibility
for you
and saying hey I got to go out and get
one little skill at a time I got a man
up woman up I got a bone up and I gotta
go into the marketplace and add value
sell a product sell a service do
something for the money work for
somebody else become the most valuable
person in your space that's what it
takes folks there's no shortcuts okay
today I'm living up here I live on the
33rd floor
of a beautiful condo
200 panes of glass in this place you got
glass all over the place okay I don't
even know what we spend to clean the
windows it's ridiculous
when I grew up
I had one little window one little
window and looked at a brick wall
okay and that's when I was a kid
as I grew up and got more of an
education my window got smaller and
smaller and smaller and I was acting
like I was a
I was acting like I was a
like I had my [__] together
okay so look got to get a good job
how do you get a good job you get the
job you're at you get good at it I don't
care what job it is
I lost five jobs all five of them they
should they probably shouldn't have
hired me and they did they gave me a
shot and I lost them I deserved to lose
all five of them they shouldn't have
kept me there as long as I was
if you got drug problems alcohol
problems you're gonna have to get rid of
them okay you're gonna have to confront
the Beast if you got a bunch of freaking
loser friends around you got to get rid
of them
you want the great life you want the
real deal life it's not about posting it
online it's about living it it's about
doing it it's about paying the price all
the successful ones paid the price
advantages of multi-family investing
number one more doors the easier to
manage and fund the project it's easier
it's just an easier deal two units
harder to manage than 22 yards because
the bigger you get the farther away you
can get from it two units you need a
manager that manager is going to charge
you at least 10 or 12 percent somebody's
going to manage the property somebody's
going to answer the phone calls four
grand a month somebody's gonna want at
least 400 bucks a month to take the
bullish phone calls number two all units
one location reduces management activity
number three one Closing one property I
could buy one deal get 300 units you buy
300 houses you need 300 closings four
one financial statement 300 units fits
on One Financial State one duplex fits
on the same financial statement number
five produce enough Revenue to hire a
management team advantages of
multi-family you could our management
team number six produces enough cash
flow to invest in capex capex circle
this word it means expenditure on the
capital of the building meaning the
Capital Improvements of the building
roof floors cabinets how many done
cabinets before use Graphics the guy
that wraps your cars in your city say
hey come wrap my cabinets I like things
done quickly I bought the house Elena's
not there I call my rap guy come in here
man
don't sand it don't paint it wrap it
boom it was done in the afternoon number
seven more units allow more amenities
two units you do not have a swimming
pool you do not have security you do not
have a gym 300 units you got a gym you
got security you got trees you got
picnics you got dog parks you got great
stuff you got Gates I have properties
where the pool at the apartment building
is nicer than the pool that we have at
our house and Elena's like where are you
going I said I'm going to the pool at
the apartment building I got some
apartment buildings the Bible says
that's I mean I'd move in there
because they got action everywhere and
the bigger the deal is the easier it is
to add value and spend money on it right
if I'm gonna spend some money man I
could spin it cross it across a bunch of
stuff rather than two units Apple
computer has two 196 billion dollars in
cash today they will borrow money
tomorrow morning debt is good some debt
is good debt and there's not a wealthy
company on this uh Planet not one
wealthy company on the planet earth that
is cash free that does not use debt I
don't want to get out of debt I want to
create wealth and the way to create
wealth is through debt and the debt is
cheap the debt is under three percent
I pay interest only I don't even pay the
mortgage down so basically what I'm
doing is prepaying my mortgage
massive amounts of margins I'm paying
down in the beginning so it stays stable
my debt stays stable and the asset goes
up in value so like a house you see the
problem with a house and you shouldn't
even have this comparison of
conversation because if I buy a house
for let's say The house's average house
about two hundred forty thousand dollars
in America and I put five percent down
you're probably over leveraged right
there
why would they give me that loan and the
house doesn't provide any income I want
to check every month I don't want to
check every quarter I want to check
every month I don't want to check 10
years from now dude I want that paper
back today I want to sell to the Goldman
Sachs and the blackstones of the world
you you can't start there but you can
level the game up to play there how many
of you have a key or retirement account
of some sort yeah good it's garbage it
was a bullish thing to rob you how many
of you own a home right now let me see a
hand
it was [__] it was [__] and you
put your money in there you wanted money
and you bought a house you wanted money
and then you put it excuse me in a
retirement account
you wanted money and then you gave it to
Wall Street you can't even get your
money
what you do man what were you thinking
oh my mama told me a house is a good
deal do you know any rich people that
say my house made me Rich
[Music]
like if I had my whole career to do over
again I would teach people about money
because basically what I've done for for
30 years you know while I was building
out these other businesses I was buying
real estate every time I'd get a surplus
of money I take the surplus of money I'd
push it off to the side okay let me just
show you the Simplicity of it okay first
of all I got to make more money
everybody agree everybody agree with
that dude you got to make more money
because if you don't make more money you
ain't got any money this is what Susie
Arman says don't spend your money don't
spend your money don't spend your money
don't spend your money you can't afford
it you can't afford it all she had to do
was go make some more money
okay
right but what did she tell you don't
spend it you can't afford it the truth
is you need to make more money number
one you got to make more money or and
really in the case don't make it you
need to collect it
or get it
who's got my money
number two what do I need to do now I
need to keep the money
it's not big words
and by the way just because it's not big
words doesn't mean it's not valuable
what am I keeping the money for I didn't
say save it by the way I said keep it I
don't need you to save money there is no
money made by Saving today how many of
you know about compound interest
you're like compound interest is the
Holy Grail no no not today it is there
is no compound if you're making point
zero four percent at the bank
today's national uh Friday's average
savings rate in America was 0.12
percent
that ain't 12 percent that's point one
two percent that's not 1.2 percent
that's 12 tenths of one percent it take
you 80 years
to make ten percent of your money
[Music]
okay my mom was earning 10 or 12 20
years ago she was earning 10 to 12
percent in the bank so every seven years
that money doubled you know the rule of
seven
the seven it was a calculator right if
you earn 10 on your money every seven
years it would roll over and double
okay do this I think this is like I
don't know 144 years to double money
[Music]
three trillion dollars sitting in Banks
how many of you have a partner you have
a partner in business
good how many of you do not have a
partner in business let me see your hand
okay yeah you do it's the bank
you took your money and you trusted a
bank with it
what does the bank do
they think the paper's so useless they
get rid of it
you can't get your money back how many
of you saw the video I did where I tried
to get a million dollars in cash for my
bank somebody said Grant you can't get
your money I said what do you mean man
got me all freaked out stopped my whole
day what you mean I can't get my money
man I saw it on my account man and it
made me I hung up with the phone with
him I'm like I want to get my money I
don't know
the things that I invest in today I
promise you will be around longer than
Facebook
listen to what I'm telling you right now
okay in your lifetime there might not be
a Facebook this phone right here how
many believe this phone this phone will
cease to exist in the next 20 years
ain't no way this phone's going to be
around 20 years from now
the things I invest in
will outlive this phone we'll outlive
Apple computer
I think about money I'm running every
day for money I'm going to bust in my
ass man I'm busting my ass every day I'm
busting my ass I I you know I'm busting
my trying to fill up the refrigerator
take care of the kids get good education
for them fuel the plane up put fuel in
the plane fly the plane take care of the
plane watch the plane invest in my
business right I I'm that's what I'm
doing all day long you know and then and
then what I'm trying to do really is I'm
trying to I'm trying to
put this money to use at some point okay
I operate with what's called what I call
is a 40 point I'm looking for 40 percent
to save on my income whatever it takes
how much money do I need to make so that
I have 40 percent
that I can take over here and shove a
big giant piece of cake into a deal I
thought I was Frugal I thought I was a
mooch because I thought it was cheap I
was told all these things because in
reality tight you know I can squeeze an
eagle off the porter people I'd go look
at a 200 I still want the price of this
stuff I think it's an apartment of what
the price of something is
um
I would look at the price of something
and it I was not cheap I was
misidentifying what the problem was the
problem for you when you look at it what
you're what you're getting is can I
reproduce that 200 pounds and you're not
sure yet
so you're not sure when you get sure
you'd be like cut yeah I'll take that
I'll take five of them
and um and and that is the key the key
is to get so confident in your ability
to reproduce money now the the this
complicates the issue because if you're
in the e-commerce space
you're in a space that literally was
just created overnight like it didn't
even exist what 10 years ago and got hot
here only in the last probably 28 months
or so
so you have the data
you have data that says wait a minute
this space didn't exist which only means
it might not exist in the future
right it could go away as fast as it can
so you have it on guard
are those birds I was with yesterday
they think everybody it wants to eat
them like they they don't trust anybody
they don't trust their owner they trust
no one and
um that's a good thing to have so that
when you look at it you're like hey is
this business going to be here is this
business going to work is new money
going to come in do I have the systems
in place do I trust my people do I trust
myself
this all changed for me with this real
estate stuff so we have I have 13 little
businesses uh and then the real estate
the real estate is the one that can't be
stopped there's nothing in the on planet
Earth short of North Korea going nuclear
nothing will stop the income that's
produced by that when you have that
coming in and I'm willing to work hard
every day like you are but I have this
machine going over here six thousand
Apartments seven thousand Apartments
eight thousand ten thousand pay me every
month a couple hundred bucks
then I'm like let's go on the trip yeah
okay who cares what jet fuel costs
because I got a machine going over here
and that should be the game for
everybody
do great at this
the earned income that the queen taxes
so heavily
and then go over there and find this
passive income that will pay you
regardless of how talented you are or
how smart you are or how well the video
does or how well the product release
does
get that passive income to be more than
the earned income hey oh you guys saying
I don't need this and I don't need that
I don't need that oh my God why you
gotta have all that how can you know
what you want
when you ain't never done it
just keep it real man I'm sitting here
on the front of a damn 180 foot yacht
leaving Monaco
tell my buddy Brandon back there I said
bro my whole life
my whole life I have been
guilty of saying I didn't need this or
that without even knowing what this or
that was
didn't tell you how many times I said
now I don't need y'all
who needs a yacht nobody needs a yacht
I've never been on a yacht man
okay like take a Jacuzzi on this yacht
while you leave other yachts in Monaco
you do this one time and I guarantee
you're gonna start thinking God damn man
how could I give me a yacht you know
what I'm saying I'm just keeping it real
with you this 10x thing makes you think
big makes you act bigger and get you
around some stuff where you're like
maybe I do need a yacht now fortunately
or unfortunately I've given this
experience to my daughter which she will
never ever forget
I hope you guys are unfortunately are
you because when you can't forget it you
can't forget it you're like God dang I'm
gonna go back to that life it's like
flying private you fly private one time
and man you will hate boarding Southwest
Airlines
fantastic man this is how everybody
should live and I'm sharing this with
you guys just so you know man how can
you know what you want when you've never
even seen it been around it nobody's
sharing it with you they're not talking
about how cool it is and good it is
because I know there's a whole bunch of
people in here gonna hate on me because
I'm showing
me and my family living on a yacht for
two weeks in the south of France I know
people gonna hate on me for that why
though why are you hating
on somebody just trying to share a
billion dollars worth of game for free
you understand I'm just telling you
share this with somebody that's always
already tell you I don't need to be rich
I don't need to be married I don't need
to have kids I don't need the vacation
in the world I don't need a car I don't
need you know uh the dream
how would you know
if you've never had it if you've never
experienced it
these are balloons for one my my
daughter's Scarlett okay she didn't know
she needed that but she knew she wanted
it
okay made me feel good about to do it
for her
so look
just remember the next time make an
agreement right now the next time you
say I don't need all that just ask
yourself if you even had that
even know what that smells like on Open
Sea in a Mediterranean
to do a trip like this and bring a bud
say hey man I got you bro
okay to bring my kids my wife on a trip
and not have to worry about the money
every second
I used to take vacations I worried about
the cost of it before the trip while I
was booking the trip during the trip and
definitely worried about it after the
trip
separate situation where you can do
anything with the people that you love
and care for look I'm looking at castles
come on
God bless be great
the thing I like about real estate is I
don't need to believe that it's there I
get to see that it's there
I don't need to believe that 95 is
occupied I can take the 100 units
and I'm somebody's going to show me 95
leases
I don't need to believe there's a pool I
can see the pool you understand now with
Wall Street bond market checking account
savings account 401ks IRAs I got to
believe
this is one of the biggest companies in
the world
3 trillion they're sitting at and they
pay .05
of a percent
half of one percent so when you look at
that and it's a piece of paper by the
way and that half a percent is fully tax
to you
fully tax which means if you're in a 50
tax bracket that's .025
that's a quarter of one percent it will
take you four years to earn one percent
on your money it would take you eight
years to earn two percent you get the
math there you got a problem if it's
just a dividend you're trying to get but
of course it's not just a dividend
you're trying to make money on this
stock in the case of the real estate
okay let's say I put a million dollars
in Apple stock or a million dollars in
Bitcoin whatever the case is the
target's a million dollars I had my last
million dollars and I threw it in a deal
it's a million it's a hundred grand it's
ten thousand pick whatever number you
want and I'm looking for a double
this has to go from 174 to 348 to hit a
double
how many believe it'll do it at some
point
probably will
now bitcoin's at 50 what is it at
forty seven thousand
so for me to double my money there it's
got to go to ninety four thousand never
been there ever probably will go there
one day if these both of these get there
within a year I gotta pay 50 taxes on
that on that exchange everybody agree
with that somewhere around 50 47
something okay if you're in California
63 I could take a million dollars
me and a couple buddies we could buy
four million dollar piece of Real Estate
already I'm already at an advantage over
apple and Bitcoin
why what's my advantage over over those
two
one million is supported by four million
dollars worth of of assets
okay that produce cash flow
even if this thing goes down from three
million to 3.2 4 million down down to
three and a half million even if it was
less valuable next week I wouldn't sell
it by the way only got a million dollars
invested in it okay I still get cash
flow from that asset you understand this
asset can go down in value and the cash
flow could actually go up
okay in 2010 assets didn't trade they
didn't trade at all we talked about this
in our VIP lunch yesterday in in 2008
9-10 even 11 the assets would not move
but the cash flow kept getting better
so this million dollars buys four
million dollars what do I need to sell
this for this asset for
in order to double my money
that's all I got to do this this has got
to be sold for five million dollars
if this sells for only one million
dollars more than I bought it for
that's only need it to go up 25
okay these two assets over here have to
go up 100 percent
for me to make the money I want to make
to get a double I got to get a hundred
percent to get a double in a real estate
deal
I only need that real estate to go up 25
do I have a coach yeah no I do not have
I mean I have my church my church is my
coach yeah yeah so any any time
you know anytime I'm like uh you know
some look some people they could get
coaches they don't even have the right
questions asked like
forget the right answer do you you know
most people don't even have the right
questions sure sure so so uh part of
part of what I do in my church is to
figure out what question I should even
be asking
um because most of the time I'm like hey
what's wrong with this well I should
like that's not even what's wrong your
family's important your dreams are
important these are the things that need
to be first on your mind every day not
last it's either the first
first last my dreams are first every day
then my wife then my kids
I could take care of my wife and my kids
now would you agree I abandoned this
this is the fuel for who I am I abandon
this dream
and then I end up I can't take care of
them
and then I'm gonna tell them what it's
all right that you didn't win no it's
not all right if you don't win you need
to win how many of you need to win more
okay if you don't control your
environment folks somebody else is going
to control your environment you guys
that run teams and run organizations if
you do not control your environment
someone else will control your
environment you are being controlled in
your environment right now CNBC CNN
MSNBC the parents the kids the Twitter
the Facebook the YouTube the Google the
Snapchats are in your environment your
friends and your relatives your uncles
your aunts the garbage dump called
planet Earth that you live on is mostly
broken people
[Applause]
control your environment it starts with
me
when I was 45 years old I'm like I'm
going to control my environment I'm
going to take every penny I have all the
energy I have all the resources I have
and I'm going to improve
if I got to go broke in the process
because I'm already broke look if you're
not fulfilled to your if you're not
reaching your full potential every day
you're broke right now spiritually broke
who do you need to be connected with
long term because you're going to have
to change your friends you're going to
have to I don't I don't mean get rid of
the friends and family that you have but
you're going to have to add some new
friends new family new peeps a new
network you know they say your network
is your network hey guys
well that's true for you to keep scaling
10xing 60.
600 6 million it's all possible I
promise you if I can do it you can do it
I went from being a guy that was a
one-man show one-man show to running
companies I got a 200 employees here 350
in our real estate Partners all around
the world and it's only because of these
four things I'm going to share with you
in the 10x income system which is
first middle second and second is hey
what is my strategy to get to the next
level three three is am I in the right
vehicle picking the right Vehicles okay
real estate's a great vehicle uh
coaching's a great Vehicle Health Care
is a great vehicle
um uh education is a great vehicle I'm
in all these but by the way right now
using online today the metaverse is
going to open up all kind of
opportunities for so many people I'll be
right there webinars online uh
phenomenal opportunity for everybody out
there if you're in a situation right now
you don't like it you don't like where
you're at you don't like what you're
doing you're limited you're stop you're
stuck okay grab this take advantage of
it okay I'm telling you it's a game
changer it's going to give you what you
need what you need
what you need
so that you can have what you deserve
everybody deserves a great life
everybody deserves the ability the
ability these guys will go crazy if I
come in here okay you deserve the
ability to um
uh to uh
Hey make more money period because the
truth is if you don't make more money
you'll never have money to invest and
you'll never get to the second Hustle
the third one the fourth one you'll
never get to the multiple flows and I
want to show you here how to get
multiple flows of income literally I
have three income flows today that I do
nothing
and they provide me with income every
single month
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Robert Kiyosaki
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there you wake up
tomorrow morning and you're on the
street and you have nothing you don't
have a single contact in your network
all you have is the knowledge and
experience that you've had throughout
your career